on est donc reparti pour notre avant
dernière séance
aujourd'hui je vais donc vous parler de
la deuxième grande famille de ce qu'on
appelle classiquement les énergies sans
carbone c'est-à-dire les énergies
renouvelables pour essayer de vous en
donner quelques éléments alors là aussi
en deux heures ont malheureusement
évidemment pas le temps de faire le tour
de la question c'est totalement
impossible
je vais vous donner quelques bases pour
essayer de comprendre de quoi on parle
et avoir quelques ordres de grandeur en
tête
pour ceux d'entre vous qui suivent un
tout petit peu l'actualité vous avez dû
constater que de temps en temps il y
avait des débats qui faisait rage sur
ceci ou cela faut-il mettre des
éoliennes pas mettre des éoliennes
faut-il faire des biocarburants ont pas
faire des biocarburants faut-il mettre
des panneaux solaires quand on est dans
le périmètre des monuments historiques
ou pas etc
voilà donc ces deux débats qui ont lieu
périodiquement et encore une fois l'idée
c'est d'essayer de vous donner quelques
ordres de grandeur pour vous permettre
de comprendre un petit peu de quoi il
retourne alors on va recommencer pas
rouvrir dictionnaire en entrée de
secours et se demander d'abord ce qu'est
une énergie renouvelable et on va de
encore une fois comment dire appelé
monsieur de la palisse à notre secours
une énergie renouvelable est une énergie
qui se renouvelle
faut que je vous ai 10 à toulouse à peu
près tout dit alors en fait il faut
quand même préciser c'est une énergie
qui se renouvelle au moins aussi vite
que la vitesse à laquelle on s'en sert
donc si on se sert du pétrole une fois
tous les 100 millions d'années
le pétrole est parfaitement
renouvelables si on se sert du pétrole
au rythme auquel on s'en sert
actuellement c'est un peu moins
renouvelables donc c'est une affaire
d'ordre de grandeur et de vitesse à
laquelle on s'en sert qu'est ce qu'on va
trouver dans cette catégorie de manière
traditionnelle
on va trouver pour commencer et vous
allez voir que c'est encore est de très
loin la source dominante d'énergies
renouvelables dans le monde
la biomasse c'est à dire ce qui pousse
le fruit de la photosynthèse et on
considère que c'est renouvelable à
partir du moment où le prélèvement opéré
par l'homme est inférieur à ce qui
pousse dans l'année par le prélèvement
opéré dans l'année est inférieur à ce
qui pousse dans l'année donc la biomasse
est typiquement une énergie
qui peut être renouvelable ou pas
renouvelable selon le bilan net que vous
avez entre la production naturelle et le
prélèvement humain si le président -
humain est inférieure à la production
naturelle on considère cette une énergie
renouvelable s'il est supérieur
considère qu'on a à faire la
déforestation et la désertification et à
ce moment on considère que ce n'est plus
vraiment de l'énergie renouvelable
la deuxième catégorie d'énergies
renouvelables c'est l'hydroélectricité
dont je vous parlerai bien évidemment
donc là on va dire que comme l'homme un
peu les moyens de remonter de lourdes
altitude de manière significative
heureusement que le climat est là pour
s'en charger tout ce qu'on peut prélever
sur l'eau qui tombe en altitude pour la
turbine et après l'avoir forcée à
descendre dans la vallée par une
conduite on considère que c'est
renouvelable
ça ne veut pas dire que c'est sans
impact encore une fois ce que je vous ai
dit dans un précédent en continue à
s'appliquer
il n'existe pas d'énergie sales ou
propres c'est toujours la dose qui fait
le poison
après on va trouver le rayonnement
solaire
là encore une fois si vous avez
l'intention de vivre 5 milliards
d'années ça soit pas renouvelable
mais enfin comme je doute que ça fasse
partie de vos plans de carrière on peut
considérer qu échelle de temps qui nous
intéresse l'énergie solaire est une
énergie renouvelable
puisque le rayonnement se renouvellent
en permanence et le prélèvement vous
allez voir les ordres de vendeurs le
prélèvement qu'on peut penser opérer et
de toute façon en dessous de ce qui
arrive sur terre le vent est une énergie
renouvelable comme je voulais dit la
dernière fois le vent est un dérivé de
l'énergie solaire puisque le vent est un
mouvement de masse d'air qui se créé
parce que vous avez des différences de
température donc de pression
ce qu'il faut retenir dès à présent
c'est que toutes les énergies
renouvelables ne se valent pas on a
souvent tendance à mettre dans un grand
paquet les énergies renouvelables en
considérant qu'elles sont propres en
considérant implicitement que le là il
n'y a pas de limite
vous allez voir que malheureusement
c'est pas vrai du tout vous allez
également voir que le développement d
j renouvelable souvent n'est pas une
affaire de recherche quelque chose qu'on
prend souvent dans les articles de
journaux c'est il faut investir de
l'argent dans la recherche sur les
énergies renouvelables bien certain
nombre d'énergies renouvelables pour
lesquelles le potentiel utilisable n'est
absolument pas en prennent de recherche
pour certains pour d'autres oui mais pas
pour toutes donc toutes les énergies
renouvelables ne se valent pas elles
n'ont pas toutes le même potentiel leur
développement n'est pas nécessairement
limitées par les mêmes facteurs
il peut y avoir des facteurs
technologiques il peut y avoir des
facteurs qui sont beaucoup plus basique
que ça elles ne sont pas disponibles de
manière équitable j'allais dire à la
surface de la planète par la force des
choses des pays tropicaux sont plus
richement dotés en énergie solaire que
le groenland et c'est donc les énergies
renouvelables
c'est certes un titre générique mais
vous allez voir que ça recouvre deux
réalités qui peuvent être extrêmement
différentes
en plus il peut arriver qu'on met dans
les énergies renouvelables des énergies
qui stricto sensu ne devrait pas
vraiment y être et y en a deux qui sont
dans cette catégorie la première c'est
l'exploitation des déchets parce que
dans l'exploitation des déchets vous
n'avez vous avez notamment
l'incinération du plastique et sauf
erreur de ma part si on considère que le
pétrole n'est pas une énergie
renouvelable
on devrait considérer que
l'approvisionnement en plastique n'est
pas plus il n'empêche que dans la
nomenclature internationale sur les
énergies renouvelables
la france également vos anciens qui font
ce genre de statistiques m l'utilisation
des déchets dans les énergies
renouvelables
donc vous allez y trouver la sidération
des déchets alors pour le papier qui
éduque et du bois malaxez ça on peut
dire que c'est renouvelable mais en
plastique encore une fois c'est plus
discutable
et puis un deuxième
qu'est ce que je veux dire un une
deuxième énergie qu'on met souvent dans
les renouvelables et qui peut y être ou
ne pas être
selon la manière dont on considère le
problème c'est la géothermie
tout simplement parce que la géothermie
comme je voulais expliquer la dernière
fois et le résultat 2 milliards d'années
d'activité radioactive au sein du globe
terrestre et ça a longuement fait monter
la température interne du globe alors
vous pouvez en ce qui concerne la
géothermie soit considéré le flux annuel
et auquel cas vous allez vous rendre
compte que le flux annuel est beaucoup
plus faible que le prélèvement qu'on
pourrait opérer au sein de la croûte
terrestre
il est très faible le flux annuel ou
bien on prélève de la chaleur sur le
stock qui est déjà accumulés et à ce
moment-là stricto sensu ça n'est pas une
énergie renouvelable
bon cela étant là aussi les ordres de
grandeur sont tels que on peut prélever
de la chaleur pendant un certain temps
au sein de la croûte terrestre ont
refroidi ray la croûte terrestre de 1
degrés seulement qu' on aurait des
milliers ou des dizaines de milliers je
sais plus j'ai fait le calcul de fois
l'énergie consommée par l'humanité en
une année donc stricto sensu
ça n'est pas renouvelable mais les
ordres de grandeurs font qu'on peut
construire considérer que saleh avant de
commencer à discuter sur ce que recouvre
exactement chaque énergie
je vais quand même vous donner une
indication importante vous rappelez plus
exactement une indication importante qui
est la contribution de chacune de ses
énergies à la consommation d'énergie de
l'humanité
je vous rappelle que la consommation
d'énergie de l'humanité actuellement est
de l'ordre de 11 milliards de tonnes
équivalent pétrole par an dont 11000
millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole
par an et au sein de cet ensemble les
énergies renouvelables représentent à
peu près 15 % et danser à peu près 15 %
vous allez trouver à peu près 10 pour le
bois à peu près cinq fonds
l'hydroélectricité et tout le reste pour
le moment c'est les fronts bonne tout le
reste est dans l'épaisseur du trait tout
le reste à peine c'est à peine
nécessaire d'en parler aujourd'hui donc
la première énergie renouvelable dans le
monde et de très loin
c'est le bois et la biomasse c'est à
dire le prélèvement opéré sur la
photosynthèse annuel
qui représente à peu près 10% de
l'énergie conserver sur notre planète et
pour une large partie de l'humanité
c'est la seule où quasiment la seule
énergie à laquelle les gens ont accès
c'est là le bois pour faire la cuisine
c'est éventuellement le bois pour se
chauffer c'est éventuellement des
excréments d'animaux utilisés pour se
chauffer les blues de ceci et de cela et
notamment dans les régions de montagne
vous avez souvent des gros ruminants
dont on utilise les bois pour se
chauffer ça peut être qu est ce que c
est là quand vous allez également
trouver des experts le bois de feu
prélevés en afrique
vous n'avez pas normalement la
déforestation là dedans
enfin bon ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que les c'est vraiment
l'utilisation comme énergie qui est
compté après vous allez trouver
l'hydroélectricité qui représente à peu
près 5% du total mondial en équivalent
primaire vous vous rappellerez de ce que
je vous ai dit la dernière fois c'est
que quand vous faites de l'électricité
vous avez deux manières de compte et
l'électricité si vous la produisent et
en faisant bouillir de l'eau
vous pouvez compter la chaleur dont vous
avez besoin pour faire bouillir le tout
vous pouvez compter le productible
électrique qui sort en sortie de votre
centrale il entre l'un et l'autre vous
avez à peu près un facteur 3 alors ça
c'est évidemment un raisonnement qui est
valide tant que vous eu le temps que
vous faites bouillir de l'eau pour faire
de l'électricité
si vous commencez par faire tomber de
l'eau sans la faire bouillir c'est à
dire que vous utilisez un barrage
évidemment vous n'avez plus du tout un
tracteur 3 entre l'énergie potentielle
ou cinétique de l'eau qui tombe et
l'électricité produite
vous avez plutôt un facteur 08 mai à des
fins de comparaison il arrive très
souvent que l'on prenne pour
l'électricité même si elle est produite
avec des moyens sa chaleur
je dis bien sans chaleur et part sans
combustion comme je baise nucléaire là
dedans sans chaleur il arrive que on
prenne ce qu'on appelle l'équivalent
primaire c'est-à-dire la quantité de
chaleur qu'il aurait fallu produire pour
faire l'électricité si on n'avait pas
utilisé 1
rage ou une éolienne ou un panneau
solaire et c'est cette équivalence que
je vous ai mises là si on ne prend pas
cette équivalence on se retrouve avec la
chose bizarroïde qui fait que la
production électrique du nucléaire et
des barrages sur terre sont à peu près
équivalente mais que vous comptez la
cour 5% de l'énergie mondiale et l'autre
pour 2%
bon ce qui est évidemment ce qu'il faut
c'est un peu la comparaison
donc là je vous ai mis l'équivalent en
primaire et à ce moment
l'hydroélectricité fait à peu près 5% du
total mondial si pour ça si je vous
avais mis l'équivalent final on aura été
à deux et quelques pour cent ça
resterait quand même le deuxième poste
donc l'hydroélectricité c'est la
deuxième source d'énergie renouvelable
dans le monde
après vous allez trouver quelque chose
dont on parle peu en france mais qui
peut être important dans d'autres zones
qui est la géothermie
après vous allez trouver les fameux
déchets dont je vous ai dit qu'il était
renouvelable pas renouvelable selon la
manière qu'on avait de considérer les
énergies renouvelables et à ce moment on
va tomber dans death approvisionnement
qui sont une fraction 2% de la
consommation énergétique mondiale
le biocarburant par exemple en 2005
alors évidemment ça augmente un petit
peu tous les ans voire beaucoup de
quelques dizaines de pour ça mais ça
reste des ordres de grandeur qui sont
faibles par rapport à la consommation
d'énergie mondiale
les biocarburants aujourd'hui par
exemple c'est 20 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole de prod2 carburant
produit et vous allez voir un peu plus
tard que 20 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole de carburant produit
c'est pas 20 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole le pétrole économisée
parce qu'il faut utiliser de l'énergie
pour produire des biocarburants j'en
parlerai donc 20 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole de biocarburants
contre presque 4000 millions de tonnes
de pétrole
donc ça reste des choses qui sont
extrêmement faibles et extrêmement
marginale pour le moment si on va vers
l'éolien en équivalent en primaire on
est encore plus bas vous voyez donc on
n'est même pas à 0 1% du total mondial
et si on va
on photovoltaïque on n'est même pas à un
cours 10000 du total mondial
donc pour le moment ce sont des énergies
qui utilise une fraction de l'espace
médiatique qui est très supérieur à leur
importance réelle à leur contribution
réelle dans le bilan mondial en france
cette conclusion est valable vous avez
ici
la contribution des énergies
renouvelables à l'approvisionnement
énergétique en france depuis 1970 et
vous voyez que vous avez et de très loin
les mêmes sources que dans le monde qui
domine c'est à dire le bois t
l'hydroélectricité d'hydroélectricité
occupe la partie basse las de ce
graphique c'est des millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole et le bois alors je
sais plus si c'est en équivalence
primaire aux finales ici mais ça change
pas l'ordre de grandeur est ici vous
avez donc le bois une bonne partie du
bois utilisé en france c'est les bûches
qui brûle dans les cheminées dans les
cheminées ouverte dans chez vous et chez
moi si vous avez luxe d'avoir une
cheminée et s'il fait froid l'hiver et
si ça vous tente de faire un feu c'est
donc quelque chose qui va représenter un
dégagement de chaleur significatif
par contre une contribution au chauffage
effectifs des habitations qui est très
faible parce que le rendement d'une
cheminée ouverte dans laquelle on allume
un feu pour faire joli c'est 5% en or de
grandeur c'est à dire que pour un
kilowatt heure ou pour un joule on va
dire de chaleur libérée par la
combustion
ben vous en avez 0.05 qui chauffe
effectivement la pièce jaurès à chauffer
petits oiseaux donc c'était de l'énergie
utile que vous avez ici c'est de laisser
encore une fois de l'énergie primaire et
vous avez au dessus de contribution que
vous pouvez voir qu'ils sont encore une
fois les déchets avec toute la question
de savoir si c'est renouvelable ou pas
renouvelable et le reste vous allez vous
dire à leur est tout ça c'est
essentiellement deux éoliennes
ben non le reste est pas essentiellement
des éoliennes pour commencer on a des
dieux qu'un blanc mais ces biocarburants
ici donc 0,6 million de tep ou encore
c'est l'équivalent on va dire de
quelques centaines de milliers de litres
dans 2 millions vidéo 2 millions non
plus enfin faire le calcul 15 07
millions ça fait six ans sont de 10
mille mètres cubes
donc vous avez ici de biocarburants qui
représente une petite fraction du
pétrole vraiment consommée puisque on a
dans le même temps qu'on se met à peu
près 95 millions de tonnes de pétrole
donc on va dire en ordre de grandeur
plus de 100 fois plus vous avez ici le
lien qui ne représente qu'une petite
partie de ses autres sources d'énergie
renouvelables là je vous ai mis
l'équivalent en électricité primaire et
vous voyez que on est dans l'ordre on
est dans le pont bill en groupe en
finale on serait en pour quelques
centaines
vous avez d'autres choses et en
particulier un truc est là aussi une
bizarrerie on pourrait dire de la
nomenclature qu'il est con compte la
chaleur récupérée dans le sol par les
pompes à chaleur
vous savez que la pompe à chaleur c'est
une machine thermodynamique dans
laquelle vous pour un kilowattheure
d'électricité injecté vous allez créer
ou récupérer plus exactement dans un
compartiment donner plus de 20 kilowatts
heure d'énergie thermique pour récupérer
les calories à l'extérieur avec un
rendement supérieur 1 cm elle s'est même
principe qu'un frigo 1
sauf que au lieu de mettre le
compartiment froid fermé vous mettez les
compartiments froid vers l'extérieur et
c'est la chaleur qui se dégage que vous
récupérez bomba le la pompe à chaleur on
comptabilise
les calories ou les joueurs qu'on a
récupéré dans l'environnement et qu'on a
amené dans les habitations en dans les
énergies renouvelables
quelque chose qui peut tout à fait se
justifier on aurait dû d'une certaine
manière
si on avait voulu parfaitement cohérent
avec cette nomenclature comptabilisé
également quelque part dans les énergies
renouvelables les apports gratuits du
soleil
c'est à dire tout simplement le fait
qu'il fait plus chaud l'été que l'hiver
auquel cas vous auriez eu quelque chose
qui aurait totalement écrasé le reste
bien évidemment donc ça ça c'est de la
chaleur récupérée dans l'environnement
grâce à une machine mise au point d'une
certaine manière il y aurait pas eu d'
incohérences a considéré que la machine
mise au point qui s'appelle une vitre et
qui permet de récupérer l'énergie
solaire en été ça se compte également
ici auquel cas je vous dis ça aurait
complètement écrasé ce que vous avez là
on compte également dans les autres
énergies en france le biogaz je vous en
parlerais un peu après
et la géothermie dont je vous parlerai
après également beaucoup donné ces
énergies renouvelables en france et ça
représente à peu près la hiérarchie que
vous pouvez la voir ailleurs dans le
monde
vous avez d'abord dubois ensuite de
l'hydroélectricité évidemment ces
proportions sont variables et ensuite
vous avez des tas de trucs un peu
exotique dont on parle beaucoup mais qui
pour le moment ne représente pas grand
chose toutes les énergies renouvelables
elles ont à l'exception de la géothermie
pour origine ce petit diagramme ce petit
diagramme qui représente les échanges
d'énergie dans enfin à la surface de la
planète entre la surface de la planète
et l'atmosphère alors certain nombre
d'entre vous ont peut être déjà vu ce
diagramme en général on s'en sert pour
illustrer les effets de serre vous voyez
du reste soit dit en passant que les
flux énergétiques qui ont été créés
entre la surface et la basse atmosphère
à cause de l'effet de serre sont des
flux qui enlève par mètre carré sont
supérieurs aux flux solaire que nous
recevons à l'origine donc c'est quelque
chose qui est très important effet de
serre je vous le redis dans
l'énergétique de la planète mais à ce
stade c'est pas ça qui m'intéresse ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de faire un focus
là dessus et d'expliquer ou de
d'indiquer plus exactement que la
planète reçoit en moyenne annuelle est
en moyenne géographique
alors si vous faites une double intégral
ou double moyenne à la fois géographique
et temporelle et bien l'ensoleillement
reçu par la planète est de l'ordre de
200 watts permet taille
donc si vous faites une moyenne
géographique sur la totalité de la
surface et la totalité de l'année un
mètre carré de surface terrestre reçoit
en moyenne 200 watts 2
de rayonnement solaire de son vote
perpendiculairement la surface
évidemment alors en fait la constante
solaire est beaucoup plus que ça sauf
que la constante solaire elle va
s'appliquer c'est à dire le rayonnement
envoyé par le soleil inquiets de rats
peu près de 4 fois 5 ne pas être un peu
près exactement de quatre fois ça va
être reçue par une sphère qui toujours
là donc vous avez l'exposition aux
rayonnements solaires simplement la
moitié du temps et l'incidence n'est pas
perpendiculaire à la surface par tous
donc si vous faites une moyenne encore
une fois vous vous retrouvez avec plus
de 200 en route l'atmosphère est à peu
près 200 au niveau du sol
ça veut dire que si vous regardez la
quantité totale d'énergie solaire reçue
par la planète au niveau du sol un
abstraction faite de ce qui a été
réfléchie par les nuages
vous vous concentrez simplement sur ce
qui arrive au sol y compris la fraction
réfléchi et bien l'ensoleillement de la
planète représente à peu près 7000 fois
la quantité d'énergie consommée par
l'humanité il est bien évident que quand
vous voyez un chiffre pareil ça va
déclencher tous les fantasmes c'est à
dire que on va se dire sept mille fois
la quantité d'énergie il est évident que
l'énergie solaire peut couvrir tous nos
besoins etc
alors en fait ça fait sept mille fois la
quantité d'énergie qu'on consomme
sauf que ça tombe sur toute la surface
terrestre et pour commencer sur les
océans ou c'est pas très facile d'aller
la récupérer et en fait ça va tomber de
manière très diffuses
c'est à dire que si vous regardez qu'est
ce qui tombe à proximité des
concentrations humaines parce que c'est
quand les matches ça vous intéresse et
bien le gisement va être beaucoup plus
faible et le grand paradoxe de l'énergie
solaire et c'est pour ça que ça c'est
peu développée jusqu'à maintenant vous
avez vu ce que représentait le
photovoltaïque et même le même le
thermique est pas beaucoup dessus le
grand paradoxe de l'énergie solaire
c'est qu'il y en a énormément
sauf que ça donne de manière très
diffuse à la surface de la planète et
c'est pas si facile que ça de
reconcentrer cette énergie qui tourne de
manière diffuse et d'une manière
générale ça c'est quelque chose qui va
être une caractéristique générale des
énergies renouvelables elles sont
diffuses et le seul cas de figure dans
lesquelles elles sont commandées à
exploiter
c'est si la nature fait pour nous un
processus de concentration derrière sans
que nous on a rien à faire et c'est pour
ça que vous allez trouver
essentiellement les forêts et
l'hydroélectricité dans l'énergie
renouvelable aujourd'hui consommée par
les hommes parce que dans 4 des forêts
la nature fait avec un très mauvais
rendement que l'on va le voir la
concentration dans les troncs d'arbres
et de la biomasse qui est un scope prêt
à l'emploi
et dans le cas de l'hydroélectricité la
nature grâce aux bassins versants vous
avez sur les montagnes vous concentre le
pied tombé dans des réservoirs en
altitude où c'est pas trop compliqué
d'aller exploiter ça si vous regardez la
france
voici à quoi ressemble l'insolation du
pays
en moyenne annuelle vous voyez c'est
relativement variable du nord au sud
puisque vous avez en grains de 50 % de
différence quand vous afin 50% sur plus
quand vous allez des ardennes vers la
côte d'azur est libre de grandeur que
vous pouvez retenir c'est que en france
l'insolation nous amène à peu près 1500
kilowattheures par mètre carré et par an
c'est ça l'ordre de grandeur de ce que
nous amène le soleil alors si vous
comment dire prenez ça sur une
installation solaire donc une
installation dont le rôle est de capter
l'énergie pour en faire de la chaleur
avec un rendement de quelques dizaines
de pour cent et bien les carnets de
carrés de panneaux solaires vous arrivez
à récupérer quelques centaines de
kilowattheures de chaleur
je vous rappelle qu'un français toutes
ces énergies confondues en équivalent
primaire et tous usages confondus c'est
à dire y compris la fabrication des
t-shirts ego paire de lunettes consomme
47 1000 kilowatts heure par personne et
par an voilà avec un mètre carré de
panneaux solaires thermiques
vous arrivez à faire quelques centaines
de kilowatts heure sur un an
c'est pas si on arrive à quelques
pourcents c'est loin d'être négligeable
ou du moins ça commence à devenir
discernable mais ça évidemment ne
remplaçant pas la totalité de ce qu'on
consomme aujourd'hui alors le principe
c'est quoi c'est d'une simplicité
biblique un vous captez de rayonnement
solaire pour chauffer de l'eau c'était
vous pouvez vous en servir pour deux
choses
ou bien prendre des douches ou bien je
fais les habitations alors pour ce fait
des habitations
comme en général est chauffée à des
températures qui ne sont pas extrêmement
élevé il faut que vous ayez une surface
radiante qu'ils soient importantes pour
que vous pour que le rendement de votre
installation soit quelque chose qui soit
pas complètement ridicule ça veut dire
ça veut dire que en pratique pour
utiliser un chauffage des habitations à
l'énergie solaire
il faut que vous ayez quelque chose qui
s'appelle un plancher chauffant
c'est à dire une surface radiante qui
couvre la totalité du plancher d'une
pièce si vous utilisez le radiateur que
je connais que je qualifierais
d'habituel elle encore ce live en
surface radiance qui est plutôt
relativement significatif parce que
c'est des vieux radiateurs en fonte
mais si vous allez dans des immeubles
neufs où il ya du chauffage collectif il
est pas rare d'avoir des radiateurs avec
des surfaces radiante qui sont
relativement faibles
une fois que vous avez ce genre de
dispositif de chauffage et que le
circuit de cette manière là c'est très
sais pas c'est pas facile d'utiliser du
chauffage solaire pourrait utiliser du
préchauffage avant de le faire passer
dans une chaudière à gaz ou au fioul ou
éventuellement électrique mais par
contre utiliser du chauffage en totalité
c'est pas facile
bon donc le principe là c'est très
simple et vous voyez que ici pour en
revenir à une chose que je vous disais
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de problème
d'investissement dans la recherche
c'est de la plomberie de base c'est
vraiment de la plomberie de base
vous avez une surface noire bleue qui
circulent par dessus un petit moteur
électrique et un plombier qui sait vous
met des serpentins dans un plancher de
recherche en histoire
1 c'est vraiment d'une simplicité
biblique pour remettre tout l'argent
vous voulez dans la recherche dans les
énergies renouvelables
ça ne changera absolument pas ce genre
de choses
la deuxième manière de se servir de
l'énergie solaire alors on peut en
mettre dans la diffusion ce qui va le
problème on peut remettre dans la
formation c'est pas votre problème mais
dans la recherche stricto sensu
ça changera pas grand chose la deuxième
manière de se servir du solaire c'est de
faire de l'électricité alors
l'électricité à partir du soleil
vous connaissez le principe vous envoyer
un photon sûr
matériaux particuliers fait de semi
conducteurs dans lequel vous avez mis
des petites impuretés qui vont bien et à
ce moment le photon met en circulation
des électrons il va exciter des
électrons qui va mettre en circulation
et ce à des élections qui circulent çà
s'appelle croit électrique donc une
installation photo électriques
c'est tout simplement une installation
dans laquelle vous convertissez
l'énergie du photon en courant
électrique
les rendements de conversion de ce genre
de panneau se balade aujourd'hui entre
20 % en laboratoire et quelques pour
cent dans une installation commerciale
standard qui n'est pas tout neuf
donc vous pouvez refaire le calcul à
partir du moment où vous avez par
exemple 10 % de rendement
et bien si vous avez mille 500
kilowattheures par mètre carré et par an
vous arrivez en sortir 100 à 150
kilowatts heures d'électricité par mètre
carré et par an sous l'angle de grandeur
que vous avez alors après vous avez deux
choses que vous pouvez faire aller cette
électricité
la première manière de vous en servir
cdh à consommer sur place
mais pour ça il faut que vous ayez
d'électricité au moment voulu et besoin
de vous en servir même moment où il ya
du soleil et alors là c'est à dessein
que j'ai pris ce petit graphique que
j'ai récupéré chez paou qui illustre
typiquement le genre de situation où
vous ne pouvez pas vous servir sur place
de l'électricité que vous avez produite
parce que à panneaux solaires en général
ça produit de l'énergie dans la journée
parce que sauf erreur de ma part
monsieur de la palisse a expliqué que la
définition de la journée c'est quand il
ya du soleil et en général on se sert de
l'éclairage la nuit
donc ce genre de graphiques c'est tout
mon truc qui ne peut pas faire avec une
installation si vous êtes obligés de
consommer l'électricité sur place vous
pouvez le faire si vous rajoutez une
batterie mais à ce moment vous devez
évidemment tenir compte du coût
énergétique de fabrication de la
batterie comme vous devez tenir compte
du coût énergétique de fabrication du
panneau si vous voulez savoir si votre
affaire est rentable énergétiquement ou
pas et si elle est combien ça vous fait
économiser
par rapport à une autre manière de
produire l'électricité là comme ailleurs
vous auront toujours besoin de tenir
compte du coût énergétique de la
production du dispositif que vous êtes
en train d'évaluer donc pour en revenir
à ce que je disais vous produisez de
l'électricité exactement ou transformés
de l'énergie de photons en électrons qui
se baladent et en pratique aujourd'hui
ceux qui se développent
significativement dans les pays
occidentaux c'est ce qu'on appelle le
photovoltaïque raccordée au réseau c'est
à dire que tout ce que vous produisez
vous crachez sur le réseau et par
ailleurs le réseau vous alimenter en
courant qui lui arrive aussi la nuit et
qui vous permet de fonctionner autre
décalage c'est un autre décalage que
vous avez avec ce genre d'installation
et qui fait que ça c'est difficile de
consommer sur place ces décalages
saisonniers on n'utilise plus
d'électricité en hiver
indépendamment du chauffage électrique
parce que on s'éclaire plus longtemps
parce que il ya un certain nombre de
d'appareils qui se met à être utilisé
l'hiver alors qu'ils sont pas utilisés
l'été par exemple l'augmentation du gang
sèche-linge près ces chemins sont moins
utilisés l'été que l'hiver etc
or la production d'ipad 2 est
particulièrement élevé l'été alors si un
jour tout le monde ce nuage climatisé on
se remettra en avoir les yeux en face
des trous d'une certaine manière mais
pour le moment le maximum de la
consommation d'électricité cet hiver
alors que ce genre de dispositif produit
surtout l'été donc deux solutions ou
bien de vous envoyer ça sur le réseau et
vous consommez à partir du réseau ce qui
revient à dire que vous confiez le
réseau la fonction de stockage
ça revient très exactement à 100 ou bien
veut nous acheter une batterie et vous
stockez sur batterie ce qui est
l'installation auto dont emma dans
laquelle l'a effectivement vous
consommer sur place
ce que vous avez produit si vous
comptiez vous acheter une batterie les
calculs montrent que en ordre de
grandeur vous allez multiplié par deux à
trois le temps de retour énergétique de
votre installation
il y avait des cas de figure si vous
utilisez des batteries d'auto dans
lesquelles le temps de retour est infini
c'est à dire que en gros
l'énergie que vous avez consommé pour
fabriquer le panneau installé et
construire la batterie et la renouveler
tous les toutes les quelques années
parce qu'une batterie a une durée de vie
qui est nettement inférieure à celle
d'un panneau et bien c'est à peu près
l'énergie que le panneau va vous fournir
et que vous allez pouvoir exploiter
déduction faite de la perte du
restockage donc à ce moment vous n'avez
pas fabriquer un dispositif qui vous
permet de produire de l'énergie stricto
sensu
c'est plutôt une pile que vous avez
fabriqué dans un truc dans lequel vous
avez investi d'énergie pour la
fabrication il va vous restituer cette
énergie plus tard mais sous une autre
forme
qu'elle s'appelle une pile a donc cessé
c'est ça le schéma de principe du
photovoltaïque
je vous parlerai après de ce qui se
passerait si on avait un toit solaire
sur chaque maison sur un autre diarra
vous avez une troisième manière de vous
servir du solaire qui est de faire des
installations de production électrique
de grande dimension avec ce qu'on
appelle le solaire à concentration alors
le solaire à concentration c'est une
idée qui est vieille
puisque l'on prête à archimède en haut à
gauche alors lui ce qui l'intéressait
c'était pas temps de produire de
l'électricité que de repousser les
ennemis dont qu'il allait faire des
miroirs paraboliques avec lesquels ils
incendiaient les bateaux dit la légende
il semblerait que la légende soit pas
complètement fausse
donc l'idée c'est de concentrer le
rayonnement solaire et de le mettre dans
l'enfer de la chaleur et de se servir de
cette chaleur pour fabriquer de
l'électricité dans une installation de
grande dimension donc là on veut c'est
plus le fait photoélectrique que vous
utilisez vous n'allez pas créer du
courant en excitant directement les
électrons avec les photons ce que vous
allez faire c'est que vous allez faire
barrage au fait exactement à un
chauffeur un dispositif de chauffage de
n'importe quoi éventuellement des sels
fondus et avec 7,7 cette source chaude à
et bien vous allez faire tourner un
alternateur classique ans l'attaquant
avec un circuit qui produit de la peur
alors pour faire de la chaleur de
manière intensive
vous avez des dispositifs variés
ici vous avez un dispositif dans lequel
vous avez un réflecteur cylindro
paraboliques qui chauffe un fluide qui
passe dans un tuyau qui est situé au
foyer ou directement le long du nom du
défunt au foyer niveau de la section et
qui va alimenter un réservoir de son
bureau de sels fondus dans lesquelles
vous avez fait qu'il va faire votre
seule chose vous pouvez avoir une
insolation direct ça c'est ellis dont
vous êtes est entendu parler vous pouvez
avoir une insolation direct d'un foyer
avec des miroirs réflecteurs situés de
part et d'autre du sol vous pouvez avoir
ce qu'on appelle deux tours solaires
donc là l'idée c'est que vous aller
chauffer très faire un tube créer une
dépression significative dont vous allez
créer un courant de conviction dans ce
genre de trucs
à l'intérieur vous mettez une hélice qui
tourne et vous faites votre électricité
comme ça le dispositif produire de
l'électricité à partir du soleil il ya
des tas de gens en ce moment qu'ils sont
en train de réfléchir à des tas de
dessin exotiques qui peuvent faire sens
c'est très clair et en particulier ce
dispositif là et d'une manière générale
tous les dispositifs dans lesquelles
vous commencez par créer une source
chaude qui est un gros réservoir de sel
fondu
c'est un dispositif dans lequel vous
pouvez vous abstraire de l'intermittence
jour nuit parce que votre réservoir s'il
est suffisamment massif et suffisamment
chaud il tient le l'absence de soleil
pendant la nuit il reste suffisamment
chaud pour continuer à alimenter la
turbine pendant la nuit on vous fait un
gros stockage de chaleur exactement
comme on a fait dans le coeur de l'été
un faux pas du tout avec la
radioactivité vous attendez que ça mon
bien en température et à ce moment vous
avez quelque chose qui permet de vous
affranchir de l'intermittence d'urnes
ski et devient un énorme avantage parce
que du coup vous n'avez pas une source
avec une grande variabilité au cours de
la journée
après on a donc vu la l'exploitation
d'énergie solaire en direct après vous
pouvez attendre que votre énergie
solaire elle est servie dans la nature
près de l'eau vous allez donc profiter
de l'énergie potentielle créé par la
remontée de l'eau en altitude et cette
remontée de l'eau en altitude
elle concerne des volumes absolument
considérable puisque vous voyez que on
parle de centaines de milliers de
kilomètres cubes par an quelqu'un un de
mes amis s'est amusé à faire le calcul
suivant que je vous laisse méditer c'est
si on faisait de l'hydroélectricité en
demandant non pas la nature de remonter
l'eau en altitude mais à l'un d'entre
vous normand thériault en altitude
donc au lieu de vous forcer à écouter
secours je voulais un panier sur le gros
et je vous force à monter au sommet de
l'immeuble h promet l étage ya avec
votre eau sur le 2 pour la verser dans
un réservoir qui va me servir ensuite à
alimenter ma conduite forcée pour faire
de l'électricité au pied de l'immeuble
et bien si je vous payent au smic le
kilowattheure électrique me revient à
quelques dizaines de milliers ou
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
donc ça c'est un service gratuit que
nous rend la nature qui est extrêmement
appréciable et en fait cette petite
blague que je viens de vous faire n'en
est pas une c'est ce que je vous avais
expliqué au moment j'ai rien n'est tout
à l'heure c'est ce que vous avez
expliqué au moment où je vous avais
parlé des énergies fossiles
en fait la nature a fait un certain
nombre de choses gratuitement pour nous
quand on va commencer à devoir les faire
en payant des gens puisque dans le
système économique
nous n'avons que le travail des
individus on n'a que ça ils veulent
avoir par la force des choses des prix
très supérieur et il n'y a absolument
rien d'hérétique à cela le plat cycle de
l'eau nous rêvons des quantités de lait
faramineuses dans l'attitude alors c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait on attend qu'elle
tombe on attend qu'elle se concentre
dans des fonds de vallées de préférence
en altitude on ferme la vallée en
mettant un de paquets de béton qui
s'appelle à barrages derrière ce barrage
on met ce qu'on appelle une conduite
forcée c'est à dire que l'on prélève de
l'eau
et on l'a fait descendre un peu plus bas
où on la turbine et l'énergie qui est
fournie par ce dispositif
et bien c'est eux et galen g h fois la
leur c'est à dire c'est l'énergie
potentielle de lucky bessan d'une
certaine altitude cela le rendement de
l'installation
alors là en l'occurrence le rendement de
l'installation est souvent assez bon on
atteint facilement sur ce genre
d'installation des rendements de 0,7 à
0,8
parce que faire tourner une turbine avec
de bons roulements à billes et bien
huilé avec de l'eau sous pression
c'est un truc où le rendement est bien
meilleur que quand on fait bouillir de
l'eau dans une centrale thermique donc
l'idée est ce que alors là vous avez
quelque chose qui parle échelle parce
que dans la majeure partie des barrages
qui ont été construits ça c'est à 2000
mètres d'altitude
et ça c'est à 500 mètres d'altitude pour
ceux d'entre vous ce dont certains
d'entre vous ont peut être déjà croisé à
la montagne ce qu'on appelle des
conduites forcées
c'est des gros union que vous voyez des
cendres vers le fond de la vallée a le
gros tuyau en question ce ça c'est à
dire c'est la canalisation qui va du
pied du barrage jusqu'à l'endroit où les
turbines et l'eau des pâtes turbine et
entier de barrage évidemment les
turbines et quelques centaines ou
quelques milliers de mètres plus bas
dans la vallée et c'est la différence
d'altitude c'est là c'est la hauteur de
chute sont appelés à hauteur de chute
qui va fournir
l'énergie qui va permettre d'obtenir de
l'électricité vous avez également ce
qu'on appelle des dispositifs au fil de
l'eau ou là par contre là était alors la
dénivelée que vous avez la hauteur de
chute que vous avez été beaucoup plus
faibles 7 10 m 15 m ça c'est les
barrages que vous avez le long du rhône
par exemple vous allez prélever de l'eau
et par un canal faire avancer le dans un
canal pendant que le lit du fleuve lui
descend et puis quand vous avez une
différence de 10 ou 15 mètres entre le
canal que vous avez créé le lit du
fleuve est bien là vous mettez ce genre
de dispositif c'est à dire un truc qui
descend d'un seul coup et une turbine
aura donc vous avez deux types de
dispositifs hydroélectriques
vous avez les barrages d'altitude et
retenu d'altitude et vous avez ce qu'on
appelle au fil de l'eau c'est à dire des
installations qui longe des fleuves et
qui permettent de turbines et de gros
délits alors là pour le coup c'est des
grandes quantités d'eau 1 mais beaucoup
plus des débits qui sont beaucoup plus
importants que quand vous avez des
barrages en altitude mais par contre sur
des hauteurs de chute qui sont beaucoup
plus faibles
vous avez également une autre
utilisation de ce genre d'installation
quand il s'agit de barrages en altitude
c'est qu'on s'en sert comme dispositif
de stockage dont vous avez le pendant de
ce truc là une pompe électrique que vous
avez là avec un tuyau qui remonte et
vous vous en servez pour stocker de
l'électricité que vous produisez à des
moments où j'en ai pas besoin
exemple typique la centrale nucléaire
produit le jour et la nuit
mais la consommation d'électricité est
en général significativement inférieur
la nuit ne serait ce que parce que
toutes les activités économiques et une
partie des gens qui ont considéré qu'il
avait le droit de dormir donc à ce
moment vous nous servez pas de
l'électricité et comme vous n'avez aucun
intérêt comment dire leleu
le fait de ne pas produire de
l'électricité la nuit avec une centrale
nucléaire mais vous fait quasiment rien
d'économiser ça ne permet pas un
combustible de vieillir moins vite
ça ne vous dispense pas d'avoir des gens
sur place qu'on vérifier ce qui se passe
en ce qui concerne la centrale
et bien vous allez payer plus cher parce
que c'est la nuit et c'est donc anglais
vous n'avez quasiment pas d'économie
marginal au fait de ne pas produire la
nuit donc plutôt que mais c'est
l'électricité partir comme ça dans la
nature on s'en sert en france pour
remonter de l'eau en altitude dans les
barrages
une petite subtilité on la vend à nous à
l'issue pardon la voir nos amis suisses
pour qu'il fasse la même chose donc nos
amis suisses économiquement ils ont
trouvé un truc absolument génial il
achète de l'électricité duke l'erreur la
nuit à bas prix pour remonter dans les
barrages et ensuite ils vendent le
mégawatt heure de pointe 10 100 fois
plus cher quand on en a vraiment besoin
pour faire sauter le réseau en ouvrant
la vanne du barrage
comme quoi ils ont le sens des affaires
et ils ont bien raison
donc ce genre de dispositif sert aussi
de dispositifs de stockage ça sert aussi
de dispositifs de stockage
cela étant vous vous rappelez 2e et
galen g h il faut remonter sur 1000
mètres d'altitude
trois mille six cents litres 2 pour
stocker un kilowattheure donc 3 6 tonnes
beau remonter sur 1000 mètres d'altitude
pour stocker un kilowatt heure c'est à
dire un dixième de litres d'essence
l'élégie mécanique
sané ça ne permet pas d densité de
stockage très élevée face à l'énergie
thermique
alors pour savoir si on peut encore
recourir ou non de manière significative
à l'hydroélectricité
voilà le genre de calcul dans de grandes
heures qu'on peut être amené à faire
l'hydroélectricité comme je voulais
expliqué deuxième chose renouvelables
dans le monde
première source d'électricité
renouvelable de très loin cinquante fois
plus importante que l'éolien aujourd'hui
pour savoir si on peut encore gratter
quelque chose ou pas gratter quelque
chose voilà alors ça c'est à calcul que
j'ai fait moi c'est un calcul d'heures
devant leur jeu vous garantit pas qu'il
soit valable avant à 20% près c'est pour
illustrer le raisonnement pour que vous
jouez vous donne électricité produite il
faut que vous ayez
qui tombe en altitude si l'on tombe en
plein pour la turbine est en pleine h
n'est pas très élevé vous allez passer à
la chose dont vous commencez par
regarder où sont les reliefs et quelle
superficie ils ont une fois que vous
avez vos relief et votre superficie vous
regarder quels sont les précipitations
annuelles sur les massifs en question
alors souvent la montagne il pleut plus
qu'en plaine donc vous avez des endroits
dans les alpes par exemple où vous avez
des précipitations qui vont jusqu'à 2000
mm souvent que tu racontes 2000 mm de
pluie dans l'année alors que les
précipitations annuelles moyennes en
france sont plutôt aux alentours de 700
800 1 donc sur les massifs et c'est
normal c'est là que vous avez des
ascendances donc c'est là que vous avez
la pluie vous avez parce que l'ascendant
segal refroidissement refroidissement et
la condensation la condensation et les
flottes
donc vous avez sur les massifs plus de
pluie d'ailleurs si vous avez la
superficie fois les précipitations
annuelles
vous avez donc le volume d'eau qui tombe
à l'altitude ce volume 2 qui tombe à
l'altitude 1 en imaginant que la
totalité vous puissiez le récupérer pour
le canaliser et en faire de
l'électricité
c'est bien évidemment un guide supérieur
eh bien ça vous donne un maximum
d'énergie potentielle possible par
enfin je veux dire accessible pouvoir la
production hydroélectrique donc là par
exemple vous prenez la france
eh bien vous avez quelque chose qui est
181 térawattheures sur les roda sur la
région rhône alpes et 65 sur le reste du
massif central et 136 sur les pyrénées
alors évidemment c'est pas comme ça que
les choses se passent d'abord vous avez
le rendement de votre installation qui
vous ampute ce potentiel maximum dans
tous les cas de figure
donc là il me semble que j'avais pris
80% ou peut-être 70%
et puis ensuite il ya un certain nombre
d'endroits où vous n'avez rien à
récupérer par exemple les vallées sont
trop petites
la hauteur de chute et pas assez élevé
vous n'allez pas faire un barrage par
balle et c'est pas possible
etc etc donc ça vous donne ce genre de
raisonnement le la limite supérieure que
vous pouvez raisonnablement atteindre
et c'est avec ce genre de raisonnement
que vous pouvez dire ou ne pas dire
quelque chose que vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu qui est que en france par
exemple on a atteint à peu près 90 % du
potentiel
bah c'est en faisant selon le calcul on
a regardé quelle était la quantité
totale d'eau qui tombaient en altitude
sur des vallées d'une certaine taille
qu'on pouvait fermer par un barrage et
avec une hauteur de chute qui soit pas
complètement ridicule ou un barrage qui
nécessitent pas des installations
totalement titanesque
voilà le genre de raisonnement qu'on
fait pour évaluer ce qu'il est possible
ou pas possible de faire c'est ce genre
de raisonnement qui la conduira des
chiffres que je vais vous donner un peu
plus tard sur ce qui reste possible dans
le monde pour faire de
l'hydroélectricité
ici vous avez une autre indication très
intéressante qui et à quoi peut servir
l'électricité produite grâce à l'eau et
en fait elle sert à deux choses qui sont
extrêmement différentes
vous avez ici la production électrique
d'edf sur une semaine divers donc on
reste chez nous et on est sur une
semaine divers vous constatez que la une
variation significative de la quantité
fois que de la puissance appelée en
fonction de l'heure vous voyez que la
l'échelle de la demi journée puisque ici
on est parti à une heure et on est 13
heures derrière et bien la puissance
appelée elle a pu passer de 45 gigawatt
1,65 gigawatts en l'espace de quelques
heures
d'accord donc pour ceux d'entre vous qui
ont travaillé dans cette boutique
eh bien il faudra faire ce qu'il faut
pour que en l'espace de quelques heures
la puissance appelée augmente de 50%
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
augmenter la puissance appelée de 50% en
quelques heures
eh bien on peut faire deux trois choses
et la première chose qu'on fait c'est
d'ouvrir les robinets des barrages le
barrage c'est un dispositif qui permet
de fournir ce qu'on appelle de
l'électricité de pointe ou d'hyperpointe
c'est à dire c'est le truc pour lequel
en quelques minutes vous pouvez passer
d'une puissance nul à la puissance
maximale de l'installation et à un gros
barrages ça peut être une grosse
puissance maximale le barrage des trois
gorges alors évidemment c'est vraiment
l'exemple d'abord il est pas nationale
enfin l'exemple de plus le barrage des
trois gorges
si ma mémoire est bonne c'est 18
gigawatts ou 20 gigawatts de puissance
installée
c'est à dire l'équivalent de 15 tranches
nucléaires en ordre de grandeur
donc c'est s'accroche même en barrages
dans les alpes c'est de l'ordre de la
puissance installée ça peut être de là
deux gigawatts
donc c'est des grosses installations
mais par contre si vous les mettez à
pleine puissance
vous n'allez pas duré très longtemps un
barrage typiquement ça peut fonctionner
l'équivalent de 500 à 1000 heures dans
l'année
donc si vous ouvrez les robinets et que
vous les laisser ouverts en permanence
et bien quand vous êtes arrivé
à la fin du mot milieu du mois de
février si vous les ouvrez le 1er
janvier il ya plus de leurs barrages
hélas ce moment pourrez plus vous en
servir donc ce qu'on fait avec les
barrages c'est de gérer ce qu'on appelle
la pointe ou l'hyper pointe et on à
l'autre hydro électricité dont je vous
ai parlé ce qu'on appelle le film de le
lui c'est l'exact inverse
c'est le truc qui vous crachent toute
l'année la même chose ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle de l'électricité de base c'est à
dire c'est de l'électricité dont on a
besoin en permanence
et là vous voyez que quoi que fassent
les français en hiver on n'a jamais -2
45 gigawatt qui sont appelés sur une
puissance installée en france qui est à
peu près de 100 101 00 part pas de zéro
donc sur une puissance installée en
france qui est de l'ordre de 100
gigawatts pour la production électrique
avec évidemment de durée d'utilisation
annuel qui ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
selon moyens que vous considérez et bien
il y en a 45 qui sont toujours en
fonctionnement et ça peut monter jusqu'à
70 75 quand y'a vraiment besoin de
beaucoup donc danser dans l'électricité
de base
ici vous avez le qu'est ce que je veux
dire
le fil de l'eau c'est à dire une partie
du lot électricité qui est extrêmement
peu souple en gros ça crache tout le
temps la même chose et l'autre partie
d'hydroélectricité elle est extrêmement
souple c'est vraiment le truc qui est
commandable à volonté et qui va
permettre de contrôler la variation de
la demande à des échelles de temps très
courte donc vous voyez ici le nucléaire
qui ne varie pas beaucoup mais qu'il
arrive quand même on peut quand même
module est un peu la production
nucléaire
pas trop ici vous avez ce qu'on appelle
le thermique à flamme ou le classique
s'il s'agit très concrètement des
centrales à charbon et des centrales à
gaz que vous avez laissé pour une partie
d'entre elles en chauffe donc elles
émettent un peu de co2 en permanence
parce que de temps en temps vous avez
besoin comme comme pour une cuisinière
où vous auriez le brûler
en veilleuse de temps en temps vous avez
besoin d'ouvrir le truc en grand pour
que votre centrale se mettent à
alimenter le réseau donc hyper coincé
d'hydroélectricité et la semi base ou
lapointe s'est fourni peu partie par des
centrales thermiques qui sont des
centrales à flamme que les présentes
hydroélectricité dans la production
électrique des divers états à la surface
de la planète
et bien voilà un graphique que vous
devrez apprendre par coeur voilà donc la
part de l'hydroélectricité est en fait
qu il faut retenir avant ce graphique
c'est les enseignements généraux et
l'enseignement général général c'est que
vous allez avoir beaucoup
d'hydroélectricité dans les pays qui
l'ont beaucoup de montagne donc si vous
prenez un pays un peuple a par exemple
amis allemands
si vous prenez à votre pays un peuple a
par exemple nos amis polonais par
exemple les grands bretons ils ont beau
avoir les highlands et quelques collines
à ça permet quand même pas de ça permet
de faire quelques fantômes et quelques
légendes mais pour l'hydroélectricité
c'est moins pratique si vous prenez les
danois et les pays-bas tout plat tout
plat et bien l'hydroélectricité pervez
stoch à l'opposé vous allez trouver ici
des pays qui sont très montagneux et les
norvège vous avez tous vu des photos de
fjords norvégiens
il ya du il ya du relief alors il ya du
relief derrière aussi l'espagne le
brésil qui a des montagnes puisque le
brésil ça pue peut être parti sur la
cordillère des andes
comme vous le savez on va de retrouver
exactement pour cette même raison le
venezuela la colombie
on va trouver le chili etc l'argentine
voilà donc les pays qui sont sur la
cordillère ont un approvisionnement
hydroélectrique significatif les pings
d'afrique où il ya du relief
on va trouver également des choses qui
peuvent être significatives et les
lignes alpin en europe donc autriche
suisse sont également des pays et la
france
et parce que la france la voilà est à 15
% ce qui est déjà pas si ridicule que ça
pour un pays qui n'est pas complètement
et uniquement montagneux vous avez ici
les le pourcentage et vous voyez que il
n'ya qu'une petite quantité de pays une
petite poignée de pays dans le monde qui
arrive à monter on va dire au dessus
d'un tiers d'électricité d'origine
hydrique
quand on voit ce genre de pratiques
évidemment on se pose la question qui
est est-ce que c'est facile de faire
mieux et plus alors une première manière
de répondre à cette question est tout
simplement de regarder comment est ce
que les pays se sont équipés et si on
est toujours dans une très forte
progression de l'équipement en barrages
ou pas et vous avez aussi deux courbes à
2,6 g plus exactement qui vous donne
l'équipement à barrage en europe et en
asie asie europe et vous voyez que en
fait on n'est pas dans une courbe de
progression ou ça n'arrête pas
d'augmenter depuis qu'on a commencé à
faire des barrages
il a eu un maximum dans les années 60 et
et depuis c'est en train de descendre
par ailleurs il ya quelque chose qu'il
faut savoir c'est que dans le monde est
la grande majorité des barrages ne sont
pas destinées à produire de
l'électricité
la première fonction des barrages dans
le monde c'est de réguler les
écoulements d'eau pour les usages
agricoles et en particulier à cette
fière d'être plus tôt pour pouvoir se
pour pouvoir avoir de l'eau quand on en
a besoin pour irriguer
et pour réguler le débit des fleuves
c'est à ça que ça sert avant tout la
production d'électricité à partir de
barrage c'est moins de la moitié des
barrages construits en mode que
d'inventer des barrages construits dans
le monde servent à des usages agricoles
alors vous devez donc que le qu'est ce
que je veux dire le la la la la
progression du nombre de barrages s'est
ralentie alors est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya plus rien à faire
ben ça dépend de la région à laquelle on
s'intéresse et vous avez ici par exemple
pour les pays d'asie
alors je suis désolé c'est en anglais
mais enfin normalement vous arriverez à
suivre j'espère que vous savez tous ce
que c'est que myanmar oui très bien
donc vous avez ici pour un certain
nombre de pays d'asie la production
possible donc le technique halliche
visible là c'est ce que je vous ai
expliqué tout à l'heure le keeper en
altitude à flot la faction des bassins
versants où techniquement on peut faire
quelque chose soit la hauteur de chute
fois le rendement voilà c'est sale c'est
ça le technique qualifie siegel et ça
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
donc vous voyez qu'il ya un certain
nombre de pays où le potentiel équipe
avait encore extrêmement important et
elle peut augmenter de manière très
significative la quantité d'électricité
produite par ce moyen
il n'empêche que la question se pose
et vous l'avez vu largement débattue
dans les journaux à l'occasion du grand
âge des trois gorges de savoir si ses
propres si c'est pas propre
parce que ça se pose là comme ailleurs
quand on a fait les barrages dans les
alpes il ya un certain nombre d'endroits
où les habitants qu'on a déplacé on
considérait ce n'est pas propre
vous avez ce n'est pas du tout d'accord
avec l'idée qu'ils ont été et lyon
l'électricité c'était propre pour
installer le barrage des trois gorges
l'ordre de grandeur qui circule
habituellement c'est qu'on a déplacé à
peu près un million de personnes et même
si ça va en choquer certains de faire
cette comparaison
je vous rappelle que l'accident de
tchernobyl ces cent cinquante mille
personnes déplacées
d'une certaine manière on peut se poser
la question oui est-ce que c'est tout
voilà donc sais je encore une fois
est-ce que c'est pas parce que c'est pas
propre à chacun d'en juger
ça n'est jamais sans inconvénients
encore une fois ça n'est jamais sans
inconvénients ensuite il ya une autre
énergie ou cat man une autre source
d'énergie renouvelable qui va être
on va regarder de près et la biomasse je
vais revenir à ce graphique ou
normalement vous connaissez les chiffres
par coeur puisqu'il aurait une interro
écrite là-dessus et je vais vous
rappeler que la photosynthèse
c'est actuellement 120 milliards de
tonnes de carbone un prix chaque année
par les être vivants alors 120 milliards
ici plus pour être très précis 50
milliards là mais pour le moment je ne
parle pas des algues bien que y ait des
gens qui s'intéressent de près à la
production de ce genre de choses mais
c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de
trouver des chiffres peu fiables les tas
de trucs qui circule partout mais les
chiffres un peu fiable et les résultats
d'études c'est pas facile donc à peu
près 120 milliards de tonnes séquestrés
par les êtres vivants test il se trouve
que là dedans vous avez aussi la
respiration des plantes
vous savez pas si vous avez la
respiration des plantes à désunir
s'il vous plaît vous avez la respiration
des plantes à déduire pour calculer ce
que les écosystèmes concert vraiment est
ce qu'on appelle la cruelle donc il se
trouve que les plantes rejette dans
l'année 60 milliards de tonnes de
carbone donc dans les sucres et l'amidon
qu'elles ont photo synthétiser en
prenant 120 milliards de tonnes de
carbone dans l'année il y en a 60 qui
repartent sous forme de co2
immédiatement parce que les planches
respire donc il vous en 60 donc votre
productivité primaires nets annuels ses
60 milliards de tonnes de carbone dans
l'année pour l'ensemble des terres
émergées alors 60 milliards de tonnes de
carbone ça vous ferait en ordre de
grandeur
de 50 à 100 milliards de tonnes
équivalent pétrole ça dépend de la
fraction d'hydrogène ça dépend de la
traction d'oxygène ce que s'il ya déjà
de l'oxygène c'est plus vous qui pouvez
oxydé d'ombré ça dépend de et cetera
dont on a de grandes aires vous êtes
entre 50 et 100 milliards de tonnes
équivalent pétrole de biomasse
synthétiser ce qui fait pas vous voyez
ça fait cinq fois la consommation
d'énergie de l'humanité c'est pas si
monstrueux que ça c'est pas si mon
souhait que ça parce que dans ce
productivité primaires nets
vous avez entreprise besoin de manger et
entre autres choses besoin de manger et
vous ne pouvez pas prélever la totalité
de la biomasse juste pour faire de
l'énergie pour alimenter des industries
car des industries 100 personnes qui
mangeaient à l'intérieur ne sont que
prospère très longtemps donc vous avez à
peu près cinq fois la quantité consommée
et on va voir que à partir de ça vous
pouvez faire énormément de choses
vous pouvez bien évidemment l'utiliser
en direct c'est la combustion du bois
quand je vous parlais tout à l'heure
et sinon vous pouvez faire des
transformations dans tous les sens alors
une partie de transformation que vous
pouvez faire sont d'ordre mécanique
je vais vous en parler après vous prenez
une plante qu'on appelle un oléagineux
c'est à dire une plante qui vous produit
de l'huile typiquement du colza et du
tournesol sous nos latitudes typiquement
des palmiers à huile sous d'autres
latitudes où du jatropha ou ce que vous
voulez et là vous avez un traitement
mécanique qui est tout simplement du
pressurage vous en sortez ce qui vous
intéresse si vous êtes très riche vous
pouvez rouler à l'huile d'olive vous en
sortez ce qui vous intéresse et vous
vous en servez comme énergie après vous
pouvez demander à des petites bêtes de
commencer à faire une partie du travail
pour vous ça c'est typiquement si vous
avez des plantes qui produisent des
sucres ou de l'amidon et vous allez
donner ça à manger à des bactéries qui
vont nous faire de l'alcool voilà ça
marche très bien pour faire du château
margaux et ça marche aussi pour faire
d'autres choses comme par exemple des
vinasses complant d'éthanol à partir de
betteraves
c'est quelque chose que les bactéries
savent faire ensuite vous pouvez amener
directement vont l'énergie thermique
pour faire non pas de la réaction confié
la réaction des bactéries mais à
fairview à la main exactement de manière
artificielle avec de l'énergie thermique
c'est la gazéification donc là vous
prenez des matériaux qui sont
suffisamment sec pour être combustible
et vous en faites de la gazéification et
enfin vous pouvez le faire également
appel à des bactéries mais à d'autres
bactéries cette fois ci qui ne vont pas
travailler en milieu aérobie donc c'est
pas des bactéries qui ont besoin
d'oxygène c'est au contraire des
bactéries qui n'aiment pas l'oxygène et
ces bactéries qui n'aiment pas l'oxygène
elles ont un métabolisme qui l'a fait
produire du méthane quand elle s'attaque
à de la matière organique et le méthane
est évidemment un gaz combustible
ça c'est comme ça que l'on fabrique le
biogaz donc la matière organique
on peut s'en servir pour faire
énormément de choses et bien évidemment
dans tous ces procédés de transformation
vous allez avoir des pertes en ligne qui
sont liées au fait que vous avez des
sous ou d'éco produits qui vous
intéresse pas ou vous avez besoin
d'injecter de l'énergie pour assurer la
transformation
typiquement la gazéification et toute la
question est de savoir quel est le
rendement brut vers net de ces diverses
filières alors je vais vous en prendre
dès qu'ils sont particulièrement
médiatiques en ce moment c'est méthyl
tertiobutylique terre si ma mémoire est
bonne et il tertio butyl éther cdc des
biocarburants qu'on obtient en ayant
coupé de l'éthanol avec de l'isobutène
ça va mieux
voilà le schéma de principe des de la
fabrication de la production des
biocarburants vous à de deux filières
important de production de biocarburants
et je vais vous illustrez à travers la
production des biocarburants les
questions d'ordre calculatoire qui se
pose pour savoir si c'est une bonne ou
une mauvaise affaire
c'est ça c'est ça de c'est ça l'esprit
de ce que je vais renconter maintenant
une première filière de production des
biocarburants consiste à partir de
plantes qui produisent du sucre ou de la
vidéo alors la vie dont c'est
typiquement le blé le maïs et le sucre
vous avez des vitres av qu'est-ce que je
hais la can se sucrent en fait il
apparaît non pas sous forme de petits
cubes prêts à être mis dans le café mais
il apparaît dans un jus que vous avez
que vous obtenez en sortie de
fermentation donc en les cultures vous
allez les pressés vous allez vous
pressez la can ou précédées betteraves
vous obtenez un jus sucré vous donner ça
à manger à vos bactéries c'est
exactement comme quand on fait du vin
vous obtenez à la fin quelque chose dans
lequel vous avez 10 à 15% d'alcool et le
reste c'est l'eau et des tas de machins
en suspension donc entre les packs
fermentation et l'étape espagnole
en fait vous avez tout un tas de trucs
qui sont pas représentés sur ce
graphique mais dont je vais vous parler
après des opérations intermédiaires qui
permettent d'obtenir de l'état de l'état
nola dira c'est à dire de l'éthanol
débarrasser de son dos et cet éthanol
vous allez oust l'injecter en direct
dans de l'essence ou bien l'utiliser
quasiment pur c'est par exemple le cas
de le 85 mais pour ça il faut adapter
les moteurs ou bien vous allez faire
réagir avec de l'isobutène et
reprendre le sigle que vous avez tout à
l'heure vous avez l'acronyme de t d
c'est à dire quelque chose qui va brûler
mais qu'il est plus d'éthanol
vous avez une deuxième filière de
biocarburants qui part des oléagineux
donc là vous prenez quelque chose qui
vous produit de l'huile et vous n'avez
pas de traitement ni bactérien ni
thermique intermédiaire vous allez
simplement pressé exactement comme quand
vous faites de l'huile de tournesol ou
de l'huile de noix vous pressez vous
filtrez et ce que vous obtenez et cette
huile ou bien vous pourriez utiliser en
direct dans un moteur très robuste très
primaire pas sophistiquée mais les
constructeurs de voitures vous
expliqueront dans les voitures modernes
il vaut mieux pas faire ça parce que
sinon vous avez tout déréglé et la
filière ordinaire on va dire c'est de
faire une double estérification et à ce
moment vous obtenez des hestayres que
vous allez mélangé au diesel ou au
gasoil avec laquelle douze acronyme de
em achevée en général
esther j'ai pu bouger trop quoi derrière
voilà maintenant un peu plus détaillé ce
qui va se passer dans le cadre de
l'éthanol parce que pour savoir combien
on a économisé dans une affaire dans
laquelle oups non plus question pour
savoir combien une affaire dans laquelle
on a eu besoin d'investir et en talent
et bien il faut regarder ce qu'on a
produit à l'arrivée mais enlever les
charges qu'on a en cours de route alors
si je prends le cas de l'éthanol vous
allez produire en pleine déroute sorte
de l'éthanol mais le tallec machin qui
ne sont pas de l'éthanol et que vous
allez pas mettre dans un réservoir de
voiture vous allez obtenir ce qu'on
appelle des pulpes de drèches c'est à
dire les résidus solides que vous avez à
la suite de votre phase de broyage vous
allez obtenir éventuellement ce qu'on
appelle des vinasses c'est-à-dire de
l'eau
débarrassé de l'alcool qu'elle contient
et ces trucs là vous pouvez en faire ou
ne pas en faire quelque chose après la
question c'est comment est ce que vous
faites une allocation de l'énergie que
vous avez besoin de consommer pour
alimenter les procédés vous avez besoin
de faire une allocation vous allez
produire un truc qui vous intéressent et
un truc qui vous intéresse - eh bien
vous avez des manières diverses de faire
ce qu'on appelle les allocations par
exemple l'énergie distillation au niveau
de l'éthanol enfin pour produire
l'éthanol vous avez aucune ville à ce
qu'enfin ou du vin rosé du vin vous
liste il est sûr que c'est du vent de
betteraves du 24 vous distillez il faut
de l'énergie pour distiller cette
énergie comment est-ce que vous
d'imputer une première manière de
l'imputer et dire je sors à la fin de la
distillation de l'éthanol d'un côté et
de la flotte de l'autre et je j'ai put
l'énergie aux très hautes et des menaces
vous allez voir a presque ça comme
signification sur sur la location une
deuxième manière de faire c'est de dire
ce qui m'intéresse
enfin c'est d'avoir un produit qui brûle
donc ce qu'est ce que je cherchais le
contenu énergétique
donc je vais faire une amputation au
prorata du contenu énergétique de ce que
je produis l'hypothèse extrême en pareil
cas c'est de dire que 100% de vos
intrants sont imputés à l'éthanol
produit parce qu'en fait elle vraiment
que ça qui vous intéresse et le reste à
une petite valeur mais enfin bon c'est
tellement petit que ce n'est pas la
peine d'attendre une troisième manière
c'est de dire aujourd'hui il ya un
étalon qui a été inventé pour comparer
tout le reste vous connaissez peut-être
cette petite citation que moi je trouve
très profonde d'une certaine manière
c'est l'argent c'est ce qu'on a inventé
pour comparer des tas de trucs qui sont
pas comparables entre eux c'est parfait
c'est exactement à ça que ça sert donc
on peut faire une allocation économique
c'est pas idiot ce s'est passé pas
illégitime en soir parce que justement
quand on parle d'économie c'est qu'on
essaye d'utiliser un indicateur
transversale qui permet de comparer tout
elle reste donc on peut faire une
allocation économique et
donc ça veut dire que ça je le vends un
certain prix ça je le vends un certain
prix sages le camp un certain prix est
jaloux mais intrants au prorata du prix
de vente de nos produits
alors cette affaire l'un a une grosse
importance parce que regarder l'exemple
de l'éthanol je vais avoir ici on entre
et un champ de blé pour produire mon blé
j'ai besoin de fabriquer des engrais ça
c'est une consommation énergétique j'ai
besoin de fabriquer mon tracteur et j'ai
besoin de le faire avancer et en sortie
je devais avoir du blé et de la paille
si je fais à ce niveau là une allocation
massique ça veut dire que la moitié des
intrants énergétique dont j'ai besoin
pour ma culture je l'affect à la paille
si je fais une allocation économique ça
ça vaut quasiment rien et la totalité de
mes intrants va se retrouver affecté au
blé ensuite j'ai une deuxième opération
donc je vais mettre de l'eau là dedans
et des bactéries qui vont tout faire à
vanter mais bastia il respire et donc
elles vont émettre du co2 il pèse ce co2
il a une masse d'accord alors il y avait
à ce niveau là je consomme pas
énormément d'énergie
mais enfin je pourrais en affecter une
petite partie par exemple énergie
fabrication de la cuy vivre je pourrais
en affecter au co2 voilà si je considère
que le co2 que je rejette dans
l'atmosphère est un truc qui naquit
n'est pas un produit recherché qui n'a
aucune valeur économique et qui est ces
gens put rien si co2 il est racheté par
coca cola pour gazéifier des bouteilles
je peux éventuellement imputé quelque
chose à ce co2 et enfin derrière vous
allez mettre de l'énergie pour distiller
votre la vinasse dans laquelle vous avez
l'état d'alors au classement le liquide
dans lequel vous avez l'éthanol et vous
allez sortir en masse beaucoup plus de
vinasse que d'éthanol scotto sangsues
donc si vous faites une allocation de
l'énergie distillation qui est une
énarque et qui est le leur
de l'énergie quand on produit de
l'éthanol prorata des masses et bien
c'est essentiellement ce qui n'est pas
l'éteindre eux qui vont récupérer une
large partie de cette énergie de
distillation alors quand je vous dis les
choses comme ça ça peut vous sembler
évident que c'est parce qu'il faut pas
faire la [ __ ] à sion massique y avait en
chef de l'état ne va pas imputer les
deux tiers de l'énergie qu'on utilise et
ben si il ya des gens qui font les
calculs comme ça et il ya une étude en
france qui a été qui a créé une
polémique très importante
malheureusement parce qu'elle est à
l'origine d'une partie de la politique
française actuelle en matière de
biocarburants qui a calculé debian est
liée à la production des biocarburants
avec une allocation massique dans ce
schéma là et pour ne pas les nommer
c'est l'ademe qui a fait ça c'est la
vienne qui a fait ça est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles aujourd'hui la
politique en faveur de l'éthanol et et
si offensive c'est parce que ces
chiffres là ont circulé partout
moi je vous pose la question j'ai mon
avis là dessus mais je vous pose la
question est-ce que c'est très légitime
quand ce qu'on cherche vraiment c'est ça
de faire une allocation massique des
intrants alors on est une autre manière
de conter qui n'est pas une manière où
on a nous mais une manière où on
soustrait et là ce qu'on fait en gros
c'est que pour chacun des coproduits
qu'on a dans cette affaire donc on
inclut tout à l'éthanol
on la produit et on fait des déductions
pour chacun des produits qui arrivent en
cours de route
donc là ce qui va servir par exemple à
l'alimentation animale la pulpe et de
racheter les résidus solides ou pâteux
que vous avez une fois que vous avez
distillés et que vous avez filtré dont
vous avez broyer votre va prendre
l'exemple de la betterave vous avait
broyé l'autre betteraves
vous avez fait un jus sucre et le jus
sucré vous donne de l'alcool vous
récupérez l'alcool par distillation et
ce qui n'est pas l'alcool c'est à la
fois de la flotte et la matière en
suspension qui va vous donner un résidu
solide au cateau et ben ce résidu solide
ou pas tu le sais ça les pulpes et les
drêches et ça ça me sert à faire de
l'alimentation animale
alors la manière dont vous pouvez
compter c'est pas
où la masse ou la valeur économique
c'est comment est ce que j'aurais fait
si j'avais pas fais méthanol si j'allais
pas fait de détail hall j'aurais
cultiver d'autres trucs genre à me les
vaches dans un pâturage j'aurais sais
pas quoi c'est quoi le contenu
énergétique et les émissions de leurs
trucs que j'aurais fait si j'avais pas
lu mais sous produit de la production
d'éthanol et à ce moment vous allez
infectés ah ça non pas en une quote-part
de l'énergie que vous avez utilisé pour
produire
l'éthanol plus les coproduits vous
allait affecter un ratio qui est les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ou la
quantité d'énergie que vous avez utilisé
pour faire autrement si vous n'avez plus
accès à ça c'est ça l'idée
1 c'est ce qu'on appelle la méthode des
impacts qualité c'est comme ça que vous
voyez des gens en faveur des énergies
renouvelables vous dire ce qui n'est pas
nécessairement illégitime 1 si je
souhaitais le truc alors j'évite temps
d'émission
c'est exactement ce genre de
raisonnement 1 si je procède comme ceux
ci allaient j'ai plus besoin d'utiliser
un bout de centrales à charbon ou à bout
de centrales à gaz comme j'aurais fait
si c'est exactement le même principe et
à ce moment votre calcul devient enfin
différents alors tout ça a peut vous
sembler très technique et ça l'est ç'a
un impact absolument majeur sur le
résultat vous avez ici pour les paroles
le gain par rapport à l'essence en
fonction de la méthode que vous utilisez
si vous êtes à zéro qu'on sente bien ça
veut dire que vous ne gagnez rien par
rapport à l'essence ça veut dire que
toute l'énergie que vous avez utilisé le
long de la chaîne pour faire les engrais
faire le tracteur faire avancer le
tracteur distillés
construire la cuve dans laquelle s'abat
serre et sa fervente distillés et c est
bien toute l'énergie que vous avez
consommé pour tous à 7 identique à
l'énergie qui est contenu dans l'éthanol
que vous avez produit d'accord dont vous
avez une opération blanche simplement
vous avez offert un débouché à quelqu'un
qui avait des betteraves ou du blé qu'il
n'avait pas en faire et du reste c'est
historiquement pour ça que la politique
des biocarburants a pris place en france
donc si vous êtes des circonstances ça
veut dire que vous n'avez rien
économiser et si vous êtes à 0% et que
vous avez produit 5 millions de tonnes
de biocarburant ou 5 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole de biocarburants ça
veut tout simplement dire que les 5
millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole
contenu dans vos biocarburants
correspondent à une dépense énergétique
2,5 millions de tonnes équivalent
pétrole que vous avez réalisé ailleurs
dans le secteur industriel dans le
secteur agricole et c'est le contenu
énergétique de veau bio carburants s'ils
sont produits à 0 % d'économies ça veut
tout simplement dire que ça correspond à
une dépense énergétique qui a été fait
ailleurs
vous avez simplement changer votre
dépense énergétique de tiroirs de tout
mais globalement pour le pays vous avez
rien gagné si vous êtes à 10%
ça veut dire que au lieu de prendre un
litre d'essence et d'avoir émis 09
damien est bien avec le litre d'éthanol
compte tenu de tout ce que vous avez dû
faire pour le produire vous avez est
visé aux 9,1
le bilan complet du litre d'éthanol c02
alors évidemment c'est zéro tout court
dans le moteur de la voiture puisque
dans le moteur de la voiture vous allez
oxydé du carbone qui était contenu dans
la biomasse et donc rendre à la crosse
faire du carbone qui a été prélevé dans
l'atmosphère il ya six mois où il ya un
an
donc vous êtes dans le cycle cours du
carbone le carême qui est oxydé dans la
chambre de combustion du moteur ne
participe pas au changement climatique
par contre pour avoir la molécule dans
votre moteur
vous avez dû consommer de l'énergie
fossile à d'autres moments où de
l'énergie tout court à d'autres moments
et tout ça mis bout à bout ça va vous
représentez 09 de ce que vous avez dans
votre moteur
alors ça s'appelait de 0,9 en énergie ou
0,9 en émissions de gaz à effet de serre
vous avez de manière d'occulter
non c'est vous êtes à 0,8 et c est là
c'est vous avez économisé la moitié ou
60% et bien dans la première
cv qui avait été publié par l'ademe on
était à plus de 50% alors que si vous
refaites le calcul avec des règles qui
personnellement me paraissent beaucoup
plus orthodoxes c'est à dire on le
contenu énergétique ou les impacts
éviter ou la valorisation économique des
coproduits vous économisez pas plus de
50% vous économiser entre 10 et 20 ce
qui veut dire encore une fois que quand
tout à l'heure je vous ai dit les
biocarburants dans le monde c'est 20
millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole
ça veut dire que d'avoir produit ces
biocarburants si on est à 0,8 par tout
ce qui n'est pas le cas parce qu'au
brésil c'est bien meilleur mais si on
était à zéro partout c'est pour vous
illustrer le raisonnement en fait sur
ces 20 millions de tonnes équivalent
pétrole de biocarburant produit on en a
vraiment économiser 24 à leucate pardon
20% fois à 20 dont 4 et les 16 autres on
les a simplement déplacé d'ailleurs
c'est c'est ce qu'on a eu besoin de
consommer dans l'agriculture et dans
l'industrie
ça c'est quelque chose qui illustre
d'une manière plus générale le fait que
quand vous regardez quelle est la
pertinence de procéder d'une autre
manière que la manière qu'on utilise
habituellement et je dirais que d'une
certaine manière ça va être une partie
centrale du prochain coup quand on
prendra du bilan carbone ça va
fondamentalement dépendre des frontières
du système c'est-à-dire juste qu est-ce
que vous portez votre champ de vision et
de la manière et des conventions de la
légitimité des conventions que vous
prenez pour faire vos calculs il
n'existe pas de résultat qui soit
indépendant des conventions qu'on a
prises pour le calculer ça n'existe pas
voilà
je vais finir cette affaire sur les
biocarburants avec un petit calcul
d'heures de grandeur la photosynthèse ne
peut agréer monsieur de la palisse par
la force des choses pas séquestrés ou
absorbé plus d'énergie que l'énergie
solaire l'énergie solaire je vous
rappelle que c'est 1200 à 1700
kilowattheures par mètre carré et par an
en france
en fait la photosynthèse vous vous
rendez compte qu'elle a un rendement qui
est de l'ordre de 0 5% en moyenne une
fraction 2%
donc la quantité totale d'énergie
produite par hectare et par an à cause
de la cotra grâce à la photosynthèse
plutôt est de l'ordre de 6 ou 7 tonnes
équivalent pétrole
ça c'est l'ordre de grandeur de ce que
vous pouvez produire sur un hectare de
terre comme matière sèche dans l'année
comme contenu énergétique de la matière
sèche dans l'année avec la photosynthèse
typiquement vous voyez 6 tonnes
équivalent pétrole sur 1 ha ça fait un
bruit un facteur de entre les deux ça
fait de l'ordre de 13 à 15 tonnes de
matière sèche par hectare et par an
regardez assemblée a changé a eu quatre
hectares 80 84 ha pardon south et 8 n
est en général vous avez un peu à peu
près équivalent de paille en fuite
puisse thèse c'est ça leur de grandeur
et c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
très productif à changle 1
donc vous êtes plat plutôt dans le haut
de la fourchette dans le forez en
général jacques en dessous les forêts
sont moins productives que les champs de
cultures annuelles
donc lors de gants d'or ces quelques
tonnes équivalent pétrole a ha c'est ça
la matière organique qui est produite
par la photosynthèse
si vous avez si vous utilisez cette
biomasse on substitue au chauffage par
exemple vous prenez le blé qui a poussé
dans l'année vous le mettez directement
ou une chaudière ce qui est quelque
chose qu'on peut parfaitement faire et
bien à ce moment le potentiel de
substitution d'un hectare de terre que
vous affecter à ce genre d' usage
c'est 3 à 4 tonnes équivalent pétrole
par an si vous commencez par en faire
des biocarburants dans les deux cas de
figure vous l'êtes plus tôt
1 vous avez vu tout à l'heure qu'avec
des méthodes correct d'allocations pour
l'éthanol ont de 4
on passe à 4 fois 0-2 donc vous êtes
plutôt aux alentours de 0,8
pep par hectare de pétrole économiser
1,2 d'énergies fossiles économiser avec
des oléagineux vous est pas déroulé le
raisonnement mais vous êtes aussi à une
fraction de tête par hectare d'énergie
en fin de course
une fois déduits les rendements de
transformation cela veut dire qu'on sait
faire ça veut dire que si but du jeu
c'est d'économiser du pétrole avec des
biocarburants rails de la matière
organique qui a poussé sur un champ il
faut beaucoup mieux pousser le chauffage
à base de céréales et de bois que de
pousser et de carburant je vous rappelle
que le gasoil et le fuel domestique
c'est le même produit pétrolier donc
faire économiser du fuel en
développement les chaudières à céréales
ou ça prouve pas très éthique mais où
faire économiser du gasoil en
développement les biocarburants c'est
très exactement la même économie de
produits pétroliers à l'arrivée et pour
nous et pour tout impliqué en france il
se trouve qu'en france la diésélisation
du parc fait que on consomme de plus en
plus de diesel et de moins en moins
d'essence
or les biocarburants qui sont tous et
fortement en avant actuellement sont des
substituts à naissance et non pas de
substituer aux deux ailes or pour le
moment on est déjà dans la situation
dans laquelle dans le pétrole brut qui
est importé en france
les raffineurs réexporte une partie de
l'essence qu'ils ont produite parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à la vente sur le
territoire français et ils sont ils sont
obligés d'importer du diesel
en plus de ce qui est produit sur le
territoire français pour alimenter les
automobilistes français ceci explique
cela c'est à dire pourquoi est ce que
dans les derniers mois
le diesel a augmenté plus vite les sens
c'est parce que vous n'avez pas de
manière homogène et isotrope l'essence
et le diesel qui augmente même pareil en
sortie de raffineries parce qu'on
consomme les deux
exactement comme ils sont produits ni
plus ni moins il ya en plus des
mouvements d'exportation et
d'importation qui viennent se rajouter
là-dessus
donc vous avez ici un exemple typique de
cas de figure dans lequel si vous
regardez les choses lui de mars
en vous demandant ce qui fait sens vous
arrivez une utilisation des énergies
renouvelables qui n'est pas celle qu'on
utilise au jour 3 qui n'est pas celle
qu'on constate aujourd'hui on devrait
faire plus tôt du diesel
enfin plus tôt le substitut au diesel
que des substituts à l'essence et on
devrait plutôt s'attaquer au chauffage
avec de la biomasse non transformé
plutôt que de commencer par la
transformer avec des tas de pertes en
ligne pour l'opération de transformation
pour aller mettre ça dans les câbles
dans les réservoirs des voitures et pour
finir ce petit calcul d'heures de
vendeurs en france on a 50 millions
d'hectares de surfaces métropolitaine
donc si vous multipliez ses parrains en
haut de fourchette ça veut dire que vous
arriverez à produire 50 millions de
tonnes équivalent pétrole de carburant
ils se font qu'actuellement on en
consomme 90 des millions de tonnes
devraient pétrole donc ça vous ben une
idée du potentiel indéniable avec les
biocarburants
vous voyez bien que là on est
typiquement sur un exemple où vous
pouvez faire toutes les recherches que
vous voulez tant qu'on sait pas toucher
à ça pas de session de recherche
je veux dire vous avez vous avez une
limite maximale et vous ne ferez pas
rouler la voiture de monsieur tout le
monde avec des vocables en voilà c'est
ça sa dépendance avait physiquement pas
possible bah dix minutes de pause et on
parle de la géothermie
m